[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد الكريشاني في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث مميزه
البدايه من هذه الصور التي تاتينا من
عاصمه النيجر النيامي وهناك هواجس قاده
الانقلاب من فرص تدخل عسكري خارجي ما زالت
قائمه حيث توجهوا الاتهام الى فرنسا
بالدفع في هذا الاتجاه
وهذه الصور من العاصمه الارمينيه ريفان
وهناك عوده لاصداء التوتر مع اذربيجان
مجددا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في تحقيق جديد لبرنامج الجزيره ما خفي
اعظم الكشف عن تعاون وثيق بين جهاز الشباك
الاسرائيلي وشركه ميثا لحذف المحتوى
المناهده لاسرائيل واقرار من داخل مجلس
الاشراف في الشركه باستخدام مفرط في تقييد
المحتوى العربي والفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
بانتقاد موجه نحو الحلفاء يتحدث عن بطء في
تسليم المساعدات الغربيه العسكريه ويقول
ان تفوق روسيا الجوي عرقل الهجوم المضاد
وقياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تقول
انها مقاتلات افته عشر قادره على تغيير
مسار الاحداث
ردا على اتهاما من سلطات الانقلاب في
النيامي الخارجيه الفرنسيه تنفي في تصريح
للجزيره الدفع نحو تدخل عسكري وبعد حديث
واشنطن عن عمليه اعاده انتشار داخل النيجر
مصادر رسميه امريكيه تقول ان طلعات
المسيرات انخفضت منذ الانقلاب
اذربيجان وارمينيا في مساحه التوتر مجددا
في اتهامات من باكو بقصف مواقع عسكريه
وتجري مناورات مشتركه مع القوات الامريكيه
تدريبات عسكريه اذربيجانيه على الحدود
وموسكو تدخل على الخط وتستدعي سفير
ارمينيا احتجاجا على مواقف بلاده
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم الجدل بشان ما تقول
اوكرانيا بخصوص عدم تحقيق تقدم في الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني في ظل تصريحات الرئيس
فلودي بان التفوق الجوي الروسي كان السبب
وراء عرقله الهجوم المضاد حتى الان منتقدا
بطء التسليح الغربي والاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي والذي يقول في اي سياق ياتي
انتقاد الاوكراني لتاخر وصول المساعدات
العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا
68% قالوا ان السبب يعود للخلاف بين كييف
وشركائها بشان اولويات ساحه المعركه بينما
قال 32% ان التاخر انما يعود لاعتبارات
لوجيستيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
كشف برنامج الجزيره التحقيقيه ما خفي اعظم
عن تعاون وثيق بين الوحده السيبرانيه
الاسرائيليه وشريكه الامريكيه بهدف ازاله
المحتوى العربي والفلسطيني المناهضه
لاسرائيل على منصتي فيسبوك وانستجرام
واعترف مسؤول الوحده السيبرانيه
الاسرائيليه السابق خلال هذا التحقيق ان
اغلب الطلبات التي ترسلها الوحده لفيسبوك
يتم الموافقه عليها في المقابل اقرت عضو
مجلس الاشراف في فيسبوك للبرنامج بوجود
استخداما مفرط لتقييد المحتوى العربي
مؤكده مطالبتها لاداره الشركه بضروره
التغيير
اعترافات صادمه كشفها المسؤول السابق
للوحده السيبرانيه الاسرائيليه التابعه
للجهاز الشباك خلال تحقيق برنامج الجزيره
ما خفي اعظم عن اشكال التعاون مع شركه
ميتا المالكه لفيسبوك لازاله المحتوى
المناهض لاسرائيل على منصاتها
لا نتحدث عن كلمه او مفرده واحده وانما
نعمل على المحتوى بطريقه اجمل صحيح ان
كميه المحتوى التي نزيلها كبيره لكوني
فضاء فيسبوك ضخما جدا
على مدار اشهر ادار فريق برنامج ما خفي
اعظم خلال التحقيق صفحتين على منصه فيسبوك
احداهما بمضمون فلسطيني بالعربيه والاخرى
بمضمون اسرائيلي بالعبريه لاختبار اليات
فيسبوك المعلنه وكشفت تجربه عن تناقض جري
فهنا مثلا قيدت الصفحه الفلسطينيه لنشر
صور شهداء فلسطينيين
الصفحه العبريه فنشرت صور تدريب مستوطنين
بينهم اطفال على السلاح وكانت منشورات
الموت للعرب متاحه الى اي تقييد او تحذير
من جانبها اقرت عضو مجلس الاشراف التابع
لشركه ميتاج
في التقييد والحظر ضد المحتوى العربي
واكدت ان مجلسها طالب اداره الشركه
بالتغيير لكن اونو انهت المقابله مع مقدم
البرنامج الزميل تامر المسحال عند السؤال
عن مدى استقلاليه المجلس الذي يضم مسؤوله
اسرائيليه سابقه انخرطت في محاربه المحتوى
الفلسطيني ماذا لو كان الامر على النقيض
مسؤول عربي او فلسطيني سابق معروف بمواقفه
المعاديه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي كيف سوف
يكون الحال لقد تجاوزنا الوقت المحدد
للمقابله
ولم يلقنا ان يكون هذا الموضوع جزء ا شكرا
[موسيقى]
للتاثير الاسرائيلي في شركه ميتا شواهد
كثيره وهو الامر الذي كشف بعضه خلال
التحقيق المسؤول السابق للسياسات العامه
في الشركه بالشرق الاوسط شركه متى في اخر
عدد من السنوات قامت بعدد من استحواذت
المهمه جدا على الشركات تقنيه وتكنولوجيه
داخل دوله اسرائيل وهذه الشركات بقت تعمل
بموظفينها والمهندسين داخل دوله اسرائيل
لكن الاكثر اثاره كان في حديث المسؤول
السابق للوحده السيبرانيه الاسرائيليه ان
التعاون مع فيسبوك تعدى الى طلب ابقاء بعض
المحتويات لاغراض استخباريه واستشهد
المسؤول الاسرائيلي بحادثه امنيه اشرف على
التنسيق بشانها شخصيا مع اداره فيسبوك
الحادثه الاخيره التي اتذكرها حين عملي
كانت ازمه خطف الشبان المستوطنين الثلاثه
في الخليل حينها لعبت فيسبوك دورا اكبر من
خلال نشرها صورا بظروف مخت لفه اتذكر
لقاءات معهم من اجل التنسيق والسير على
نهج موحد لكنه تنسيق على المستوى
الاستراتيجي اكثر منه على المستوى العملي
ارسل فريق البرنامج بعد انتهاء التحقيق
رساله مفصله لاداره فيسبوك للرد على
الاتهامات ونتائج تحقيق ما خفي اعظم لكن
دون اي رد
معنى الان من رام الله اياد الرفاعي
الباحث المختص في الحقوق الرقميه اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد الرفاعي ما العمل الان
فلسطينيا في ضوء ما كشفه البرنامج
يعني العمل وهذه المؤشرات والدلائل
الخطيره يعني على مسار دائره هذا الحيز
الهام وهذا الفضاء والوسيط المهم في
التواصل البشري بشكل عام مصادره هذه
الميزه من اياد الفلسطينيين
وتقنين وتحجيم طريقه استخدامهم لهذه
المنصه هو امر ليس وليد هذه اللحظه
الفلسطينيون يعانون من هذا الاستهداف منذ
اكثر من ثمان سنوات وتحديدا مع موجه
عمليات الطعن التي جرت بين عامي 2015
و2016 حينها بدات المعركه والهجوم من قبل
فيسبوك على المحتوى الفلسطيني وفي حين
اهتم ازاله اكثر من 200 صفحه وحساب
لمستخدمين فلسطينيين على اثر تفاعلهم مع
الاحداث الدائره في فلسطين المطلوب اليوم
هو ضغط من كافه المستويات والجهات ان كان
مؤسسات مجتمع مدنيه او مؤسسات حكوميه او
نحن كافراد ايضا ومستخدمين
لمنصه فيسبوك ومختلف منصات متى وايضا سائر
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي عبر فضاء
الانترنت لان ما يحدث هو انتهاك صارخ
لحقوق المستخدمين ونحن ايضا اليوم يعني
نعيش في عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهذه البرمجيات تستمد
معلوماتها وتستمد
الافكار وتستمد التاريخ المنشور عبر مختلف
المنصات ومن ضمنها منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي فما هو مستقبل الروايه
الفلسطينيه عندما يتم مصادرتها من قبل هذه
المنصات عندما تكون غير موجوده على فيسبوك
وسائر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي فهذه
البرمجيات في المستقبل سوف تروي القصه قصه
هذا الصراع وقصه الشرق الاوسط من منظور
واحد ودون وجود
للراي الفلسطيني فيها تكثيف الجهود الذي
تشير اليه تتوقع ان يؤثر على اداره متى
ويجعلها ربما تراجع بعض السياسات لديها
يعني السياسات التي
تدعم التي تكون هي اساس الهجوم على
المحتوى الفلسطيني هي السياسات فضفاضه
تسمح للعديد من الجهات الاستناد عليها
لمهاجمه المحتوى الفلسطيني وبدايه حل هذا
الاشكال يجب ان يكون بمراجعه شامله وواسعه
لهذه السياسات وتخصيصها والارتكاز على
مواثيق ومعاهدات دوليه توضح ما هو خطاب
الكراهيه وتوضح ما هو التحريض على العنف
وتوضح ما هو المسموح بتداوله بشان قضايا
الصراع
والحروب حول العالم ليس فقط هو حصرا يعني
على الحاله الفلسطينيه هناك انحياز من قبل
اداره ميتالي كثير من القضايا الساخنه حول
العالم و احدى هذه القضايا يعني هي القضيه
الفلسطينيه وباختلاف اللغات يعني الامر
ليس ايضا مقتصرا على اللغه العربيه هناك
العديد من النشطاء الذين تم استهداف
صفحاتهم اما من خلال اغلاقها او من خلال
منحهم من استخدام بعض الخصائص في هذا
الفضاء نتيجه تفاعلهم ودعمهم للروايه
الفلسطينيه وللحق الفلسطيني شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد اياد الرفاعي من رام الله
الان معنا من ولايه مصر دراغنا كورن
المحضره في جامعه هارفرد ومديره مؤسسه
توطين للمستخدمين المعنيه بحريه الاستخدام
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اهلا بك سيدتي هل
هناك الان قضيه مصداقيه فعلا بالنسبه
لشركه ميتا في هذا الموضوع
بكل تاكيد هناك قضيه على الصعيد التقني
وعلى الصعيد
القانوني والسياسي علينا ان ندرك بان هناك
انحيازا خوارزميا يحدث بسبب الانحياز
السياسي
وايضا علينا ان نقول ان الحكومه على سبيل
المثال الحكومه الالمانيه تدفع لشركات مثل
متى ولديهم سياسات معينه لانه يجب ان يكون
هناك
محتوى معين بصفات معينه وايضا اسرائيل
محميه وهي تملي كيف للناس ان يتحدثوا وباي
طريقه يتحدثون ايضا اذا بهذا المعنى الدول
قادره على التلاعب بهذا المضمون ويبعده عن
اي حريه ربما مطلوبه في هذا المنبر
هناك الكثير من الحقوق الرقميه والمنظمات
المعنيه بها تتحدث لصالح الفلسطينيين
الذين لا يستطيعون التحدث لصالح انفسهم
وهناك عده منظمات تقوم بهذا في هذا الصدد
اكاديميون امثالي ايضا يقومون بالبحث في
هذا الموضوع ولكن المحزن هو ان
الفلسطينيين انفسهم حتى لو نشروا ان هناك
انحيازا ضدي على هذه المنصه على الارجح
سوف يتم حذفها وشطبها بسرعه اذا ما العمل
في هذه الحاله
يكون هناك مكافحه على صعيد التكنولوجي
وعلى الصعيد السياسي ليس هناك تنظيمات في
الولايات المتحده تهدف الى حمايه الحريه
بالتساوي على سبيل المثال كما كنتم تحدثتم
مع ضيفكم السابق الافارقه الامريكان في
الولايات المتحده
يتحدثون عن حوادث عنصريه ضدهم وفيسبوك
يشطبها ولكن اذا ما كان هناك اشخاص بيض
يتحدثوا عن الناس السود والعنصريه ضدهم من
السود فهم يبقونها رغم انه يجب ان يكون
العكس هو الصحيح اذا على صعيد السياسه
هناك حاجه للحمايه ضد الناس
والضعفاء ايضا هناك على صعيد التكني يجب
ان يكون هناك عمل مع هذه الانحيازات
الخوارزميه مثل تلك التي تحضر كلمات شهيد
او ما شابهها طالما الانحياز وخوارزمي مثل
ما تقولين سيدتي
مع اي جهه يجب الحديث في متى حتى تراجع
بعض هذه الامور
اعلاميه كبرى الجزيره
لها قواعد يجب ان تحترمها وفيسبوك شركه
ليست شركه اعلاميه ليس عليهم ذلك انا كنت
لاتحدث مع مدير قسم الخصوصيه هناك وايضا
مع مجلس الاداره لان هناك هيئات اشرافيه
في مجلس الاداره تنظر فيه قضيه الشيخ جراح
وايضا قضايا الفلسطينيين الاخرى
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد ادراجنا كورن من
[موسيقى]
ابدى الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي مرزينس
كنتقاده لبطئ التسليح الغربي وفرض
العقوبات على روسيا واقر جيلانسكي بان
التفوق الجوي الروسي يعرقل الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها مقاتلات اف
16 لن تحقق نصرا على الفور لكنها قادره مع
ذلك على تغيير مسار الاحداث بالاثناء
تتواصل المواجهات الضاريه خصوصا على
المحور الشرقي لاوكرانيا
الروسي هو ما يكبر الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد ياسف الرئيس الاوكراني مما وصفه
بالتباطؤ والتقاعس الغربي عن مد الجيش
الاوكراني بالدعم العسكري الكافي لاحداث
تكافؤ بين القوتين
ترى سنه عسكريه تمنح روسيا الهيمنه الجويه
وهي ميزه تشتكي منها كييف باستمرار وتريد
تسويتها والحقيقه ان العدد الدقيق
والقدرات التشغيليه للقوات الجويه الروسيه
هي بالطبع سر عسكري لكن مارك ميلي رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه افصح بان الروس
يمتلكون مئات من مقاتلات الجيلين الرابع
والخامس تستخدم القوات الجويه الروسيه في
ساحه المعركه باوكرانيا قنابل ذكيه
زيناتها 500 كجم مزوده بانظمه يو ام بي كي
وهي ذات قدره تدميريه عاليه تلعب
المروحيات الروسيه من طراز كي اي 52 وام
اي 28 المجهزه بصواريخ موجهه دورا حاسما
في صد الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني فقد
استطاعت هذه المروحيات تدمير دبابات
الالمانيه والمركبات المضره الاوكرانيه
اما المقاتلات الروسيه من طراز سوخوي 30
اس ام وسخوي 24 فقد كشف انها تشكل تهديدا
للاسطول الاوكراني ودمرت زوارق الانزال
الاوكرانيه تعمل روسيا على تكريس السيطره
على اجواء المعركه من خلال طائرات اي 50
التي تقوم بالاستطلاع وتحديد الاهداف بما
في ذلك الطائرات المسيره تمتلك روسيا
مقاتلات قادره على اسقاط اف 16 بنجاح خاصه
35 المقاتل الثقيله التي تمتلك قدرات
عاليه وكذلك الطائره الاعتراضيه بعيده
المدى ميغ واحد وثلاثون المخصصه لاطلاق
صواريخ كينجال والتي استخدمت لتدمير
بطاريات باتروت فيكي
اضافه الى منظومات الدفاع الجوي خاصه
منظومه اس 400
تطلب كيف من الغرب عتادا يمكنها من كسر
هذه المعادله التي تظهر تفوقا روسيا
وبالنظر الى ساحه المعركه فانه رغم تفوق
روسيا على اوكرانيا من حيث القدرات الجويه
فان موسكو لم تستطع بعد عام ونصف من
القتال حسب الحرب ذلك انما يحدث بين روسيا
واوكرانيا صراع جو ارض وفق الخبراء
العسكريين يطلب زيلينسكي تحديدا 160 طائره
اف 16 يرى ان هذا العدد من المقاتلات
الامريكيه الصنع هو القادر على تحدي
التفوق الروسي في الجو وكانت كييف قد
تسلمت من الغرب ثلاث منظومات دفاع جوي
متقدمه وهي منظومه المصنعه بشكل مشترك بين
الولايات المتحده والنرويج ومنظومه
ايرستيل الالمانيه المضاده للطائرات
ومنظومه من احدث اسلحه الدفاع الجوي لدى
الولايات المتحده وتبادل الانتقادات بين
كييف والغرب بشان الدعم العسكري الجوي ي
ذكر بحلقات سابقه ابانا طلب الجيش
الاوكراني دبابات ابرز الامريكيه وليفرد
الالمانيه ومؤخرا احجام برلين عن
امدادكييف بصواريخ كروز خشيه اطلاقها لضرب
اهداف داخل روسيا بينما تتردد الاداره
الامريكيه في منح الضوء الاخضر لامداد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ ارض ارض من نوع
[موسيقى]
معنا الان من عمان لواء فايزه دويريا
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك سيد اللواء هذا التبرير الذي قدمه
زيلنسكي لتبرير عدم تقدم الهجوم المضاد
بالتفوق الجوي الروسي الى اي مدى هو دقيق
عسكريا
لا هو اتى على ذكر سبب واحد من جمله اسباب
نعم اتفق بان التفوق الجوي والتفوق الجوي
هو نسبه 10 الى واحد الفين طائره روسيه ما
بين مجنحه معترضه
وهجوميه قاذفه وطائره عموديه مقابل 200
طائره في الجانب الاوكراني تقريبا
وبالتالي نعم هناك تفوق جوي ولكن هناك
جمله من الاسباب التي ادت الى هذا التعثر
اهمها شبكه التحصينات
المزوده بحقول الغام بعمق 15 حزام
مكعبات اسمنتيه اثناء التنين
اسلحه مقاومه الدبابات
الكمائن الجويه والعرضيه وطريقه اداره
المعركه يقابل ذلك الهجوم الاوكراني في
بداياته ومن ثم تم تبرير هذا التاخر بانها
مرحله تمهيديه كان على جبهات ضيقه ضد
اهداف حاسمه والاهداف الحاسمه مدافع عنها
بصوره مثاليه وبالتالي حدث ما حدث وحدث
هذا التباطؤ وبالتالي قيل انها المرحله
التمهيديه لكن السؤال الاخطر ماذا اذا فشل
هذا الهجوم المضاد ماذا يعني ذلك هذا يعني
كارثه انجاز التعبير اولا تدمير كافه قوات
النخبه الاوكرانيه التي تم اعدادها
وتدريبها وتسليحها من قبل الغرب وما بعد
ذلك في يعني في دراسات الحرب اي هجوم مضاد
يتم احتوائه لا ان يتم بعد ذلك هجوم معاكس
على المستوى العملياتي هل الجيش الاوكراني
اذا فشله هجوم المضاد قادر على استيعاب
الهجوم المعاكس الروسي اذا هنا الموقف
ضبابي جدا ان ما لم يكن ما لم يكن اؤكد ان
هذا التصريح ياتي في سياق الحاحث الطلب
والخداع الاستراتيجي اذا كان توصيفا
واقعيا فالعمر مربط جدا اذا فيما يتعلق
بطائرات اف 16 عندما تحصل عليها اوكرانيا
ما الذي يمكن ان يتغير في هذا الحال
يعني الان الطلب 160 طائره انا قلت لك
يوجد في روسيا الفي طائره مقاتله ما بين
عموديه وما بين مجنحه معترضه او قاذفه
يعني عندما نتحدث عن 160 طائره اف 16 هذه
كما قال الرئيس هي لن تغير مجرى الحرب
ولكنها تساعد في تامين سيطره جويه محليه
او
اسناد جوي قريب محدود للقوات الهجوم
المضاد لكنها لا تغير الكثير لان ميزان
القوى لا يزال مختل شكرا جزيلا لك
من عمان
هذا وانطلقت في كل من دنيتش ولوجانس
وزاباولوجيا وخيرسون انطلقت عمليه
الاقتراع الاختيار نوابا للبرلمانات
المحليه والمجالس الشعبيه في اطار
انتخابات المحليه تجريها روسيا هي الاولى
من نوعها منذ ضم موسكو لهذه المناطق قبل
نحو عام ويشارك في هذه الانتخابات التي
تستمر حتى الاحد ممثلون عن الاحزاب
الروسيه الرئيسيه المتمثله بالحزب الحاكم
روسيا الموحده حزب الشيوعي والحزب
الليبرالي الديمقراطي وحزب روسيا العادله
الى جانب العديد من الاحزاب المحليه وقد
اتخذت سلطات الاجراءات امنيه مشدده في
مراكز الاقتراع التي اعلنت عنها لجنه
الانتخابات المركزيه في وقت متاخر تجنبا
لقصفها من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
افادت وكاله رويترز ان الامم المتحده
ابلغت روسيا انه سيكون بامكان البنك
الزراعي الروسي الوصول الى نظام سويفت
بنهايه الشهر الجاري ما يمكن السلطات
الروسيه من تصدير منتجاتها الزراعيه
والاسمده ونقلت الوكاله عن رساله من
الامين العام للامم المتحده
لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان البنك المذكور
سيكون بامكانه طلب الوصول الى نظام
التحويلات المصرفيه العالمي المعروف
بالنظام السويدي اذا عادت موسكو لاتفاق
الحبوب وفي ردها على هذا الموضوع حذرت
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه من ان تخفيف نظام
العقوبات على روسيا في مقابل احياء صفقه
الحبوب سيكون انتصارا لما سمته الابتزاز
الغذائيه الروسي ودعوه لموسكو لموجات
جديده اخرى من مثل هذا الابتزاز
هذا وقد كشفت الحكومه البريطانيه ان
طائرات سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني تقوم
بمهام لحمايه سفن الشحن التي تحمل الحبوب
من اوكرانيا في عقاب الهجمات الروسيه وفي
الاسابيع الاخيره قامت الطائرات
البريطانيه بدوريات فوق البحر الاسود لردع
روسيا عن شن ضربات على السفن المدنيه
وقالت الحكومه البريطانيه انها ستستخدم
المعلومات الاستخباريه والمراقبه
والاستطلاع لمراقبه النشاط الروسي في
البحر الاسود
يتميز موقف لندن من موسكو بالتشدد منذ
بدايه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ولكن تصلب
المواقف البريطانيه من روسيا ضاربه في
التاريخ الامبراطوري للبلدين صحيح ان
الدولتين تحالفتا في اكثر من حرب ولكنهما
سرعان ما عاده في كل مره الى العداء على
ما يدين مختلفه من افغانستان الى اوكرانيا
جمال العرضاوي يقلب بعض صفحات هذا التاريخ
الطويل في تقريره من لندن
[موسيقى]
لندن ابنه لندن الروماني تظل تحافظ على
بقايا الحجر الامبراطوري وتتقلب على مرمى
منه بين الشروق والغروب من هنا من جرينتش
تقسم لندن العالم نصفين كما تريد هناك نصف
ضد روسيا بالقوه ونصف اخر مع اوكرانيا
بالفعل منذ ان بدات الشمس تنحسر على
مستعمراتها اصبحت لندن تفضل الاشعاع
الامريكي على ما تبقى من بصيص الانوار
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
اطلق من جديد عنان التفكير السياسي
الانجلو امريكي بعيدا عن الفكر القاري
الاوروبي ولكن الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اعادت الجنوح البريطاني الى سواحل اوروبا
في اطار الحلف الاطلسي موسكو هي الفزاعه
التي ترقبها لندن منذ قرون الى الايام
الاخيره في اوكرانيا بدات العلاقات منذ
حكم ايفان الرهيب الذي منح التجار
البريطانيين الكثير من المزايا والاعفاءات
الى ان فكر في الزواج من الملكه اليزابيث
الاولى
التي صدد
[موسيقى]
لم تكن العلاقات بين البلدين وطيده وان
كانت قديمه تعود الى ايفان رهيب والملكه
اليزابيث بريطانيا تبقى نائيه عن روسيا
جغرافيا وسيكولوجيا
علاقه بريطانيا وروسيا امتدت على مدى قرون
وانتسمت بتوليد التحالفات والحروب
تغيرت الاحداثيات اكثر من مره حيث كانت
بريطانيا منهمكه في اللعبه الاوروبيه ولكن
في العصر الحديث دائما ما يكون بين روسيا
وبريطانيا ثالث وغالبا امريكا امريكا منذ
ان كانت مستعمره بريطانيه وهي موضوع جدل
بين روسيا وبريطانيا فقد حصل ان طلب الملك
جورج الثالث
بان ترسل الجنود الروس لقمع الامريكيين
الثائرين من اجل استقلالهم
رفضت الامبراطوره واسست جامعه الحياد
المسلح في البحار ضد القرصنه البريطانيه
تولت بعد ذلك التحالفات والحروب بين
الجانبين بما في ذلك التحالف ضد نابليون
فحرب القرم وصولا الى الاحتلال السوفياتي
البريطاني المشترك لايران خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه قبل ذلك جرت اللعبه
الكبرى بين البلدين على اراضي اسيا الوسطى
اصبح مصطلح اللعبه الكبرى دارجا لفضل ريشه
الكاتب البريطاني الهندي المولد رودي الذي
لخص انشطار العالم بقوله الشرق شرق والغرب
غرب وهما لا يلتقيان الذي وصفه بريطاني
اخر هو جورج اورويل لنبي الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه
حرب البارده في مقالته القصيره انتم
والقنبله النوويه
بالقرب من خط غرينتش اتم حزب العمال
الاشتراكيه الديمقراطي الروسي انعقاده في
لندن وهناك انقسم المشروع الى بلاشفه
ومناشفه هنا كانت الغلبه لشق فلاديمير
اوليانو في لندن قبل ان يتم له النصر في
روسيا وقبل ان يجد ثورته في مواجهه حلف
تقوده بريطانيا حاول منذ ذلك الوقت فصل
اوكرانيا عن روسيا
قبل الاحتفالي بالذكرى الاولى للمصري على
النازيه اعطت شرشل الاشاره برفع الستار
الحديدي بين المحسكرين في خطابه الشهير
بمدينه بولتون الامريكيه
اشد موقفا قد تكون الحرب على اوكرانيا في
حاجه الى مفكرين روس من امثال
خرب يغلبون السلم على الحرب وفي حاجه الى
بريطانيين من امثالك
ليشرحوا اللعبه الكبرى الراهنه ويحذر
العالم مره تلو اخرى انتم والقنبله
النوويه
بين بريطانيا وروسيا هناك دائما لعبه كبرى
لعبه امبراطوريه خطيره لا تتوقف وان تغيرت
ميادينها في القرن التاسع عشر كانت
افغانستان وما حولها الميدان في القرن
العشرين قسم ستارها الحديدي العالم نصفين
اما الان فقد انتقلت هذه اللعبه الكبرى
الى اوروبا نفسها وعلى ما يبدو فان
اوكرانيا هي الشوط الحاسم جمال العرباوي
الجزيره لندن بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان
الناموسكو استدعت السفيره الاربعين لديها
على خلفيه شكاوى من بينها تعليقات ادلى
بها رئيس البرلمان الارماني بشان المتحدثه
باسم الوزاره ماريا وانتقد البيان ايضا ما
وصفه بانه عدد من الافعال غير الوديه من
جانب ارمينيا بما في ذلك تدريبات مشتركه
مزمعه مع الولايات المتحده وارسال شحنات
مساعدات انسانيه الى اوكرانيا
من جهه اخرى نفت وزاره الخارجيه الارمنيه
تقرير باكو بشان قصف المواقع الاذربيجانيه
وبحسب ما نقلت الوكاله الرسميه للاخبار عن
الوزاره فان بيان وزاره الدفاع
الاذربيجانيه بان وحدات من القوات المسلحه
الارمينيه اطلقت النار في اتجاه المواقع
الاذربيجانيه الواقعه في الجزء الجنوبي
الغربي من الحدود هي معلومات مضلله وكانت
الحدود الارمنيه الاذربيجانيه شهدت موجه
جديده من التوتر مطلع الشهر الحالي حيث
اعلنت ارمينيا مقتل ثلاثه من جنودها بينما
اعلنت اذربيجان اصابه ثلاثه من جنودها في
اطلاق نار متبادل
ومع استمرار التوتر العسكري بين ارمينيا
اذربيجان على خلفيه قضيه كراباخ تجدد
بتجدد ياريفان مطالبتها باعاده فتح ممر
لاتشين لايصال مساعدات الى السكان
الارمنيين في الاقليم وتطالب اذربيجان
باعطائها ممرا مماثلا يمكنها من الوصول
الى اقليم نخت شيفان وراء الحدود الارمنيه
في الاثناء تعقد اللجنه العسكريه
الاذربيجانيه الايرانيه اجتماعا يوم السبت
بينما تجري ارمينيا مناوره مع الولايات
المتحده خلال ايام
بين ارمينيا واذربيجان مقومات الصراعات
التقليديه لكن الصراع محصور في بقعه
جغرافيه واحده تحمل كثيرا من التعقيدات
عنوان الصراع الابرز ومنه وحوله وعليه
تتشابكون نقاط التوتر على هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه يدور صراع منذ ان خرجت باكو
ويرثان من العباءه السوفيتيه
انذاك اندلع صراع مسلح سيطرت اثره ارمينيا
على كاراباخ ومناطق واسعه حوله تقدر ب 20%
من مساحه اذربيجان وقبل ثلاث سنوات تجدد
القتال لتستعيد اثر بيجان بعد سته اسابيع
من المعارك سيطرتها على معظم الاراضي
مدعومه من تركيا
استعاده سيطره باكو على اراضيها بقيت
منقوصه بفعل اتفاق لوقف الاعمال العدائيه
الذي رعته روسيا فرغم خساره ارمينيا الحرب
بقي الاقليم وفق الاتفاق تحت اشراف قوه
حفظ السلام الروسيه
لتبقى داخل الاقليم مناطق ما تسمى
بجمهوريه ارتساخ غير المعترف بها دوليا
والمدعومه من ارمينيا
واعطى الاتفاق ارمينيا ممرا الى المناطق
الانفصاليه هو ممر لاتشي بينما وعدت
اذربيجان بالحصول على طريق يصلها باراضيها
ما وراء الحدود الارمينيه اقليم نخت شيفان
من اجبان الى اردوغان لكن ذلك لم ينفذ
فردت باكو باغلاق معبر لاتشين مؤخرا اتهمت
يريفان باكو بتجويع السكان الارمينيين في
كرباخ وطالبت بفتح ممر لاتشين لايصال
المساعدات وافقت اذربيجان وطلبت بدورها
بفتح ممر يسمح لها بادخال المساعدات
للمواطنين الاذربيجانيين في الاقليم عبر
معبره اقدام وسط هذه التوترات يتوقع ان
تشهد ما تسمى بجمهوريه ارتساخ انتخابات
ولكن التطورات الاخطر بداها رئيس الحكومه
الارمينيه
باعتماد لهجه تصعيد غير مسبوقه تجاه
حليفته روسيا
اقر الرجل ان السياسه بلاده بالاعتماد على
روسيا لضمان امنها هي خطا استراتيجي
تلى ذلك الاعلان عن مناورات ارمينيه
امريكيه مشتركه تنطلق في غضون ايام
لتعلن اذربيجان عن اجتماع اللجنه العسكريه
المشتركه مع ايران
وبهذا تختلط اوراق النزاع من جديد بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان تولد تحالفات
وتنتهي اخرى
هذا وقد دعت القائمه باعمال مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون الاوروبيه
والاوراسيه يورو كيم دعت الى فتح معبر
لاتشين المعبر الوحيد الذي يربط ارمينيا
باقليم كراباخ وايصال الامدادات الانسانيه
الى الاقليم جاء ذلك خلال اتصالين هاتفيين
اجرتهما بكل من وزير الخارجيه الارمنيه
قرارات ميزوريان ووزير الخارجيه الاذر
بجاني جيهون بيراموف وقالت في تغريدات على
منصه اكس ان فتح الطرق والمحادثات
المباشره امر اساسي لحل القضايا العالقه
بين البلدين
تنضم الينا من لندن السيده الدكتوره تمارا
درجاتي الاكاديميه والباحثه المختصه في
شؤون القوقاز اهلا بك سيدتي الى اين يمكن
ان يصل هذا التوتر بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
ان نعرف ذلك لاني اعرف ان لا احد من
الجانبين
لا يود ان يفقد المزيد من الضحايا قبل بضع
سنوات كان الشباب هم الذين فقدوا حياتهم
لذلك لا احد منهما يريد حربا جديده يبدو
ان كل دوله يقف وراها داعم خارجي هل هذا
هل هذا التوتر الجديد نتيجه تحريك الاطراف
الخارجيه للملف
اعتقد ان كون الارمانيين
قد
قالوا انه
سيكون هناك مناورات مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هم يقومون بمثل هذه
المناورات منذ سنوات
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه
للذربيجان يقومون بمناره مع الغرب
اذا في هذه الحاله يعني
كونهم قالوا ذلك الان لانهم يريدون اثاره
الروس ويجعلهم يقلقون
هذه الاشاره تحديدا هل هل هل هل الموقف
الغربي من روسيا لعب دورا في تاجيج
المشكل من جديد بين اذربيجان وارمينيا
لا اعتقد ذلك لا اعتقد ذلك بالضروره لان
الغرب
ليس من مصلحه ان يجعل ما يوده الغرب هو
السلام
يودون ان يحل السلام في المنطقه
ولكن اعتقد
انه
انها مساله روسيه الروس هم الضامنون
للاتفاق
والارمنيون مستاءون من انهم
بان الروس لم يقفوا الى جانب ارمينيا وما
يحدث بالنسبه لممر لاتشين هو ان البجاني
الاذريين يراقبون ويفتشون جميعا نقاط
بدعوى
مكافحه التهريب
الارمانيون يتركون الاذاريين يفعلون ذلك
والارمانيين يعتقد ان يعتقدون ان اصدقائهم
الروس كان عليهم ان يراقبوا ذلك الممر لكن
كل ذلك جزء من الاتفاق وضرب الجان عرضت
على
ارمينيا ممرا اخرا لايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه والادويه لكن يبدو انهم لا
يريدون ذلك لان ذلك قد يكونوا مرادفا
للاستسلام
اذا هم يوجدون وضعا لسوء الحظ
سيتطلب نوعا من التدخل الروسي لكن في
الوقت الحاضر ما يزال الوضع على ما هو
عليه
والارمانيون
يؤكدون على مراقبه تهريب الاسلحه
عبر ذلك الممر
والالمانيون يريدون استخدام هذا الممر
وليس هناك تواصل اكثر اذا سيظل الوضع
معلقا هذا الوضع معلقا شكرا لك دكتوره
تمارا درجاتي من لندن
[موسيقى]
باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ان باريس تدعم المبادرات والجهود
الاقليميه لحل الازمه وعوده الشرعيه في
النيجر وشدد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه في تصريحا للجزيره على تمسك
بلاده بالحله الدبلوماسيه في النيجر رافضا
اي اتهامات لفرنسا بالدفع نحو تدخل عسكريا
هناك
سمعنا الكلام عن تدخل عسكري هذا يعني شيء
اذا نحن هذا ليس قرار فرنسا سنتابع
القرارات التي تاخذها
الجماعه الاقتصاديه
اي شخص
لا احد يريد حل الا حل يعني دبلوماسي عن
طريق
الحوار الوساطه العقوبات فهذا ما نسر عليه
في الاثناء تواصلوا قوه الامن فرض طوقها
الامنيه على السفاره الفرنسيه في نيامي
وتمنع الدخول او الخروج من مقر البعث
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه دون تفتيش وتتهم
سلطات الانقلاب في النيجر فرنسا بانها
تهدد السلم والامن الدوليين بالبحث عن سبل
للتدخل العسكري في النيجر من ناحيه اخرى
تقول مجموعه اكواس انها لا تزال تفسح
المجال للجهود الدبلوماسيه لاعاده النظام
الدستوري في النيجر رغم قرارها بالتدخل
العسكري هناك
لا تزال عناصر التوتر والترقب المجهول
تسود الاجواء في النيجر ولا تزال التطورات
المتعلقه بانقلاب السادس والعشرين من
يوليو وما تبعه من اجراءات بينها قرار طرد
السفير الفرنسي من البلاد وتداعيات رفض
باريس لذلك تسيطر على الانباء قوات الامن
تواصل تطويق مقر السفاره في العاصمه نيالي
ويخضع محيطها لاجراءات الامنيه مشدده في
ضوء قرار المجلس العسكري سحب الحصانه
الدبلوماسيه الممنوحه للسفير وزير
الخارجيه في الحكومه التي عينها قاده
الانقلاب اتهم فرنسا بانها هددت السلمة
والامن الدوليين بالبحث عن سبل للتدخل
عسكريا في النيجر وقال ان السلطات بصدد
تسليم الامين العام للامم المتحده خطابا
مفصلا يبين انتهاكات فرنسا ومجموعه اكواز
للقانون الدولي مشيرا الى ان عقوبات اكواس
الراهنه ضد النيجر غير قانونيه وتنتهك
حقوق الانسان
بينما تقول اكواس انها ما زالت عند موقفها
بافساح المجال للوساطه الدبلوماسيه لانهاء
الازمه ولم تحدد بعد اي موعد لتنفيذ قرار
المجموعه بالتدخل في النيجر لاستعاده
النظام الدستوري تاتي هذه التطورات
المتزامنه مع مباشره وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تنفيذ عمليات اعاده انتشار بعض
قواتها داخل النيجر مع سحب افراد غير
اساسيين ووصفت نائبه المتحدث باسم الوزاره
سابرينا سند ذلك بانه اجراء احترازي مشيره
الى عدم وجود تهديد ملموس لتلك القوات
وقالت المسئوله الامريكيه ان العمليه تشمل
اعاده انتشار بعض القوات وبعض المعدات من
القاعده الجويه
101 في ميامي الى القاعده الجويه في
اغاديز وان وضع القوات الامريكيه في
النيجر لم يتغير فيما تقول مصادر رسميه
الامريكيه ان الطلعات الجويه
للمسيرات من القاعده الامريكيه في النيجر
انخفض منذ الانقلاب
[موسيقى]
القواعد العسكريه للدول المختلفه كلها
جاءت في اطار مجابهه وجود المجموعات
المسلحه في تلك المنطقه بحسب دراسات فان
الاحداث المرتبطه بهذه المجموعات في منطقه
الساحه الخاصه بوركينا فاسو ومالي وغرب
النيجر ارتفعت الى سبعه اضعاف منذ العام
2017 واصبحت المنطقه رخوه ما عزز الصراع
بين القوى العالميه الباحثه عن موطئ قدم
لها او تمدد في القاره الافريقيه طبيعه
الحدود في منطقه الساحل والفقر والنزاعات
العرقيه والقبليه وضعف الانظمه الحاكمه
وانتشار البطاله واستثمار شعور الرفض ضد
الوجود الاجنبي في افريقيا كلها عوامل
استغلت هذه المجموعات منذ ان بدات تغلهلها
في المنطقه خلال العقود الاربعه الاخيره
على الخريطه هنا
نشاهد انتشار ابرز المجموعات باللون
الاحمر تشاهدون بعض التقديرات المتعلقه
بوجود تنظيم القاعده باللون الاخضر ما
يعتقد انها منطقه لوجود مجموعه انصار
الاسلام في هذه المنطقه بين النيجر ومالي
تقديرات بوجودي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
وهنا بين النيجر
ونيجيريا وتشاد يعتقد انه مكان وجود
مجموعه بوكو حرم
ابرز العمليات التي جاءت في اطار مجابات
هذا الوجود كانت عمليه سيرفال في مالي
التي اطلقت في يناير
2013 لمكافحه المجموعات المسلحه التي
استولت على شمال مالي وكانت تهدد بالتمدد
جنوبا ثم جاءت عمليه برخان في اغسطس اب
عام 2014
وكلى العمليتين كانت بقياده فرنسا وتوقفت
برخان عند اتخاذ فرنسا لقرار سحب قواتها
منبال العام الماضي
معنا من نواكشوط سيد اعمر شيخنا مدير
المركز الاقليمي للابحاث والاستشارات
والباحث المتخصص في الشان الافريقي اهلا
وسهلا بك
الى اي مدى يمكن اعتبار
مجابهه الحركات المسلحه في منطقه الساحل
سببا وجيها لبقاء هذه القوات الاجنبيه في
المنطقه
مرحبا استاذ محمد اهلا وسهلا للاسف ان
المجتمع الدولي وحتى الاقليمي لم يبذل
الجهد المناسب لحل مشاكل نطاق الساحل وام
او اس المشاكل في قضيه الساحل هي قضيه
اقليم ازواد كانت هنالك فرصه ثمينه منذ
سنوات 2013
ابان التدخل الفرنسي والاهتمام الدولي
وابانه تصاعد قضايا الارهاب وظهور الحركات
المسلحه لحل هذه المشكله من خلال جهد دولي
واقليمي يمكن من توحيد الدوله الماليه وحل
مشكله الازوات بمنح حكم ذاتي واسع
الصلاحيات بالسكان المحليين والسكان
المحليين هم الاقدر على تطهير الاقليم
والمنطقه من الارهاب ولكن الذي حدث للاسف
هو ان هنالك تخاذل دولي وهنالك اجنده
ولعبه امم كبرى وهنالك دول تت لمصالحها
الخاصه وايضا النخبه الماليه التي تقع
عليها المسؤوليه بالدرجه الرئيسيه لم تبذل
جهدا
لتامين الدوله الماليه واكتساب مناعه من
الارهاب للاسف ان الارهاب الذي ظهر في
المنطقه ويتصاعد حتى الان هو يقوم بعمليه
تخادم مكشوفه مع بعض الاجهزه الدوليه
والمحليه والنتيجه هي اننا وصلنا للاسف
الشديد الى هذا المستوى الخطير
يعني
سيدي عمر شيخنا اذا خرجت فرنسا من المنطقه
تدريجيا هي توحي بان الكاسب الحقيقي من
وراء خروجها هي هذه المجموعات هل هذا دقيق
هذا غير دقيق لان فرنسا موجوده منذ 2013
في المنطقه
وتصاعد الارهاب الى اعلى المستويات ولم
تبذل اي جهد لحل المشاكل الحقيقيه
المتمثله في تقويه دول بمنطقه الساحل ودعم
الديمقراطيه وفي دعم التنميه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه لان المشكل تنموي بدرجه
رئيسيه الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون
تحدث مؤخرا بمقابله بان ما تدفعه الدوله
الماليه لمرتزقه فاغنر كفيل بحل مشاكل
مالي اقتصاديا وتنمويا وهذا صحيح تدفع
الان تسعه مليون اورو لمرتزقه فاغنر بينما
سكان الشمال مالي يعيشون حاله من البؤس
والهشاشه القضيه اليوم اصبحت تجاوزت ازواد
الذي يمثل كردستان لطاقه الساحل اصبحت
القضيه اليوم في شمال غرب بوركينا فاسو
وفي غرب النيجر مكتب شؤون
[موسيقى]
المنطقه الان تشهد انقلابات عسكريه اصبحت
الجيوش مهتمه بمجالات اخرى غير الامن
وازدادت الاوضاع سوءا هنالك حاجه منطقه
الساحل للتوجه لتعزيز الديمقراطيه وتقويه
الدول وبناء مصالحات وعقد اجتماعي كبير
هذا هو الحل الذي سيستاصل الارهاب من
جذوره الارهاب اليوم اصبح جامعات مستوطنه
بعضها قادم من المشرق قاده
تنظيم الدوله يستوطنون الان في منطقه
الضوات وفي منطقه بوركينا فاسو اذا قضيه
كبرى تشابه ما حدث بالمشرق الذي اسفر عن
تمزيق المشرق العربي وتدخلات روسيه
وامريكيه هي لعبه كبرى تقوم الان والضحيه
هو المجتمعات في منطقه الساحل ولا يمكن ان
يعول على حل الا حل داخل يقوم على
الديمقراطيه وعلى التنميه الاقتصاديه وعلى
تقويه المناعه المحليه شكرا ج زيلا لك سيد
عامر شيخنا مدير المركز الاقليمي للابحاث
والاستشارات كنت معنا من نواكشوط
[موسيقى]
في زمن الطوفان المعرفي ما زال هناك
763 مليون شخص محرومين من القراءه
والكتابه ومن ان يشاركوننا لذه القراءه او
ان يكتبوا لاحبائهم ولو مجرد رساله بسيطه
عبر الهاتف الاسباب عديده وكلها حزينه
وضعت هؤلاء في سله الحرمان اما بسبب
الحروب او الفقر او انهم ولدوا في قرى
مهمشه نائيه اليوم هو مناسبه عالميه
باعلان اممي لنتذكر هؤلاء لنلتفت اليهم
بعضهم قد يكونوا قريبا منا وقد يكون يسيرا
جدا ايضا ان مد لهم يد العون
بامكاننا بحركه بسيطه ان نساهم في هذا
المجهود نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]